so one thing maybe get the news out of
the way even after the conversation is
uh the deliveries so
we've been going through a couple of
years
of obviously a turmoil and
i would even say suffering economic and
otherwise
and one of the incredible things is on
the supply chain despite all those
challenges that uh
uh tesla and elon were still able to
deliver a large number of vehicles i
don't these days pay as close of
attention as i used to in terms of the
deliveries because i used to be
fascinated by sort of the number
of semiautonomous robots that are out
there
the hundreds of thousands which is still
incredible to me so i think they were
able to set another record with
308
000 vehicles delivered in quarter four
of um
this year making that a total of almost
a million vehicles for this year
936 000 so
936
000 vehicles delivered by tesla i missed
all the supply chain difficulties
amongst all the growth they're going
through amongst all the doubters
i think you'll listen to the podcast and
uh
you can you can listen to what elon says
about the dollars includes the letters
fck
that and you can fill in the blank
you